it's 11:30 a.m. in Beijing nerves are
frayed it's nearly lunchtime and finding
food is all that matters
whether it's takeout or eating in the
lunch break is a vital part of the work
day in China more important some say
than any meeting main Sun and one Shing
have no time to leave their dance studio
so they order out with a nap
they can enjoy home-cooked meals
delivered by women living in the
neighborhood MS Jia lives just a few
streets away and she receives the order
six different dishes have been ordered
all of which she'll prepare in her
kitchen at home
she's been retired for eight years not
unusual in a country where women often
finish working at 50 go through what we
hire my daughter says I should do this
as long as I can loves my food she's
married has her own home now and I'm
alone here so that's how I'm able to
cook meals for others prepare food for
my customers so that everyone can try it
stinky tofu a la mama Jia sometimes she
prepares more than 40 meals a day just
as mother would make and inexpensive to
just three to five euros a box
most internet startups are located in
the up market district of Wang Ching
Park in Beijing this is where the
home-cooked app was launched 18 months
ago in the beginning the apps designers
simply asked housewives and supermarkets
whether they would like to cook for them
now there are more than 50,000 private
chefs cooking dishes from their home
provinces and more than a million
customers who want to eat them Hoover
and Airbnb are apps where individuals
offer a service and these were started
in America but as for food no one thinks
more about it than the Chinese food is
very important to us so it's not
surprising that an app where individuals
offer meals cooked in their homes was
conceived in China we're proud of it
lunch is served
everything is tested thoroughly from
menus to hygiene to the ingredients
every day at least 10 dishes from
private cooks are tested by the apps
founder ton Jin this is always how we do
it we all come from different regions in
China so different meals are ordered and
everyone can try it this is the best
part of our job a key part of the app
success is Beijing's army of food
couriers they deliver around the clock
but for MS Jia it's the personal touch
she delivers the food herself
on her electric scooter she is quick to
reach her customers the food's here
in the dance studio everyone knows her
the young dancers order food from her at
least once a week ms gia delivers good
food to happy customers squid in garlic
leaves and stinky tofu just two of the
favorites the developers must have had
us in mind when they created this app
we've moved away but what we order makes
us feel closer to home I order food from
her so often that she knows exactly how
I like my food prepared she knows I
don't like it made with too much oil
she's just like my mother a short break
in the afternoon and MS Jia reads the
feedback from her clients five stars all
around the food was hot and tasty she
brought it by personally it reminded me
of the food my mother made
you